die hoffnung auf der einen seite mit der
militärischen hilfe genau darüber wollen
wir jetzt sprechen mit paul ronzheimer
live aus kiew paul wie hast du den
besuch von beust johnson wahrgenommen
ist ein historischer besuch für die
menschen in der ukraine und sicherlich
auch als zeichen an die welt nennen
johnson war nicht einfach nur
präsidentenpalast sondern er hat diesen
spaziergang durch kiew gemacht zumindest
durch teile der stadt und das ist auch
das zeichen in kiew ist es jetzt nicht
mehr notwendig überall immer eine
schusssichere weste zu tragen es ist
wieder hoffnung ist gibt wieder die
möglichkeit dass hier das leben wieder
offener wird ähnlich wie es in lemberg
ja in den vergangenen monaten bereit war
dass sich fiat langsam befreit aus
diesem zustand selbst angegriffen zu
werden die bedrohung selbst eingekesselt
werden aber gleichzeitig ist natürlich
die bedrohung des krieges und der
tatsächliche krieg weiter vorhanden im
osten und das ist auch das worüber rolf
johnson zusammen mit seelands die
gesprochen hat es geht darum wie schafft
man es dass man den militärischen erfolg
den man auch hier in kiew erzielt hat
dass man diesen militärischen erfolg
auch im dom was im osten erzielen kann
also den erfolg der verteidigung denn
dort im donbass wird jetzt die taktik
offenbar geändert man hat so berichtet
cnn ein general ausgetauscht und ein
bussi general dort installierte bereits
für den syrien feldzug von wladimir
putin zuständig war und dort 2016 mit
grausamen methoden aleppo eingenommen
hat mit ja überhaupt keiner beherrschung
mehr was die angriffe auf zivilisten
angeht wir werden davon ausgehen müssen
dass die gräueltaten im osten werden
noch einmal über das hinausgehen was wir
hier rundum butscher erlebt haben dass
es so schlimm wenn ich noch schlimmer
werden könnte als in mariupol und
deswegen so hoffnungsvoll der besuch von
horst johnson er in der hauptstadt war
zu wenig ist die angst davor dass am
ende die mir putin doch noch erfolgreich
werden konnte gebannt
erst von allein jetzt buess johnson
dazwischen war auch noch der
österreichische bundeskanzler vor ort
warum sind diese besucher so wichtig und
warum sind das nicht nur
solidaritätsbesuch sondern auch was die
militärischen hilfen angeht ganz ganz
wichtige besucher
es geht immer darum um militärische
hilfe über militärische hilfe zu
sprechen es geht darum dass es weitere
hilfe gibt hierfür die ukraine es geht
darum dass man auch darüber spricht wie
man die europäische union zum beispiel
für noch mehr sanktionen gewinnen kann
aus ukrainische perspektive jetzt denn
da hakt es ja auch weiterhin es geht
weiter auch mein gas und öl embargo es
geht darum was man jetzt sachen militär
für noch machen kann und ich hatte ja am
freitagabend nach dem borderline besuch
mit modemesse lenz gerne interview zu
führen dort war erneut sehr emotional
und hat gesagt wir brauchen jetzt eure
hilfe es geht hier um jede jede stunde
denn der militärschlag oder die große
offensive im osten die steht sehr
wahrscheinlich kurz bevor wir haben wir
bereits am freitag einen raketenangriff
auf kramer tors keine stadt im osten
erlebt wo so viele menschen herum
gekommen sind die einfach nur weg
wollten ihn raus wollen aus der stadt
die dort mit ihren koffern am bahnhof
statt du hast das lange interview das
emotionale exklusive interview was du
mit zielen geführt hast schon
angesprochen da ging es auch speziell um
das verhältnis zu deutschland und auch
um die unterstützung für die ukraine von
der deutschen seite aus wenn wir uns mal
boris johnson und
auch die deutsche unterstützung angucken
welche reaktion von exzellenz die
welchen unterschied hast du da
wahrgenommen
die
unterstützung von großbritannien war
sehr viel größer als die deutschlands
zumindest was militärschiffe angeht
johnson hat sofort waffen geliefert und
auch am umfang der beeindruckend ist und
deswegen ist das was ihm entgegenschlägt
dafür freundlicher als das was unser
bundeskanzler gesteckt auch in dem
interview da hat sie denn es geht zwar
angedeutet dass man hofft das ist jetzt
ein richtungswechsel gibt dass er so ein
bisschen das auch erkennt andermatt
leichter ihr erneut erklärt wie
enttäuscht da war von der kälte so sagt
der deutschen regierung
vielen dank paul ronzheimer du hältst
uns weiter aus kiew auf dem laufenden
vielen dank für den moment